i don't regret what you made me
[Music]
hopefully at the end of this challenge
the two of them are still gonna be
sleeping in the same bed
excuse me stop vibing you gotta get
writing
it's not even a game anymore welcome to
song lab a show where our talented
songwriter producers get paired up with
musicians and have only
two hours to create an original song the
most voted song will be the winner and
the team will get a
prize get ready for song
[Music]
hi everyone we have here with us our
super talented song lab producers
what's up everyone my name is dear
evergreen i am a producer and i
predominantly make vocal driven indie
electronica hey my name is simon cerveda
and i'm a producer from toronto canada i
mainly do hip hop production right now
and today we brought
two special musicians who also happen to
be a couple
i see blue
[Music]
what's good my name is brian chin i'm a
singer songwriter and producer
my name is kayla steen and i am a
recording artist
singer and songwriter
[Music]
my relationship with kayla is fire
i met him in a bar like three years ago
and i was just like hey
you know i'm kayla he wasn't into it
because i guess i was too bubbly and
he's like real chill
he fell in love with me after we both
had a bottle of fantasy
she's a way better singer than i am he
can play multiple instruments and
produce anything
i do wish i could play an instrument i
did play the harp but
i don't know how to play that no more
actually you know if someone brought a
harp around
i could do it do you guys live together
he is in the other room yeah separated
by a wall
now we need to decide what the teams are
going to be
three two one and the results are
brian you will be on team evergreen
and kayla you'll be on team simon it's
not even a game anymore
for today's song battle the theme is
breakups firefight let's go okay team
simon
the three words for your team's lyrics
are
missing jealous and x
team evergreen and the three words for
your team's lyrics are
tear regret and pain
each team will have two hours to create
an original song with the theme of
breakups
and use the selected three words in your
lyrics that were suggested by our
followers
i hope you all have fun and may the best
song win
if anything happens just go to his room
and unplug his computer we won't do that
i'm really amped i haven't had any
caffeine all like for like the past week
and then i just drink have you ever had
a yerba have i
i want to take your hip-hop influence in
the beat
and then i will carry it vocally in an
art like in a 90s r b
sort of a way yeah okay i think we have
to do the step by step so let's get a
chord progression down first what
instrument sound do you like
i like guitar oh oh that's perfect
because i don't know how to do that
you don't okay keys do keys the words i
have to include
tear it's regret and dark
i'm down to keep it pretty like minor
and moody
[Music]
how do you feel about that beautiful
love it
can i just like hum what i just did to
you yeah yeah that's
that's the easiest option okay
sorry okay
[Music]
this is so fun to watch when we're
adding drums let's wake it up
because right now it's sleepy are you
thinking like this kind of drums
[Music]
[Music]
yeah let's take it there okay
okay let me just add some hats for some
groove and then i'll send this over to
you
[Music]
it's so weird because i can hear him
he's like already singing
that's crazy while he's vocal recording
to start screaming
shed no tear no shade no stress no fear
no fade i'm honestly really excited
about these scratch vocals because i
already like
have something cool that i'm going to do
with them and i'm excited to show you
the idea just like hit me like right
across the face and i was like oh yeah
second sorry i think i burped in your
ear i apologize when i'm super nervous i
burp a lot
we're not talking by the way this is on
the internet i don't have to record
myself
cause i don't wanna be next to my ex
i'm just out here trying to relax i
thought you know
hurry up coming on
that's pretty crazy that would have
taken me two weeks to write that
no i usually take forever but we don't
have time
hey guys how are you guys doing good
i'm here to give you guys a challenge we
love you yeah
your team must incorporate a voice
message to your song that was sent to us
by our followers
and you were willing to do it but i was
a coward and i know that
but you don't know what is going on
inside of me and that's okay i'm stuck
somewhere else and
i don't think you'll be able to
understand later that this could this is
the best decision that i could have made
for us
wow um okay you don't have to use the
whole memo
but you have to incorporate it somehow
good luck guys and see you at the end oh
thank you
thank you it was so sad but i think we
could keep the
ending part where she's like i made the
best decision for me it's more than like
i'm sorry i have to i'm not the girl
we're writing for is not sorry
my instinct would be to chop it up and
trigger it then it could be used kind of
like where i would normally do
ad-libs or something let's move in that
direction for sure
no stop vibing you gotta get writing
what are you doing
stop by me you gotta get riding fire
okay i'm out i'm out
[Music]
i love those keys
[Music]
i can hear him
[Laughter]
x is the only way to have left okay i'm
just gonna freestyle i don't know
i'll keep you jealous
but next time you'll be worried about me
i'll keep you jealous
i got it out
should i call brian i need help with
something okay i'm going to get him
i need help with something okay
hold on okay
i just want to send him these harmonies
export [ __ ]
thank you good we're good okay
bye now it looks like we have 30 minutes
left
could you send me the hook oh you're
saying bounce this out
i mean if it's a convenient time you
know what i mean yeah so here's the
thing
i think that bouncing it out is going to
take too much time i'll show you the
tune with you so you can kind of hear
where we're at
and then maybe get an idea i'm just
doing like layers and stacks and stuff
if you can get that over to me within
the next 10 that would be phenomenal
then a song you'd be worried about me i
keep you jealous
that is not the right harmony but it's
fine let's see what happens how's it
coming on your end
you good brian on sending those vocals
over yeah how much time did they say
five minutes
can you take that one out simon which
one
can you take the bed next time harmony
out i can i can pitch correct it
it is so annoying though if you want to
you got this we got this yeah right here
where is this oh it's gonna get close
i said just delete it it's okay
are you exporting those
yeah okay decision that i could have
made for us
okay not bad i think the i would just
make the vocals even better
i can't believe we did that the wave
titled vox 2
yeah should be the one that starts right
at the beginning that's the verse the
pre
and then box hook and box hook two
uh those can just start at the beginning
of the hook
oh i'm not getting this i'm sorry
okay i mean i can share my screen but
we're gonna have time
what are we calling it again i mean we
could call it breakup to break through
uh we don't have a name for it yet oh my
god um
four five okay okay
god i hate cornyal's names um let's just
call it jealous
how you feeling i feel like i just
blacked out for two hours
how are you feeling where am i putting
it oh oh you're doing something never
right
answer your question is after 10 years i
said how are you feeling
i'm doing good yeah this was this was
stressful i don't know until like time
went a lot faster this time
i don't even know the song that well to
not receive the book the vocals from
brian
until literally the very last minute
that was really really tough
we pulled through we did what needed to
be done within two hours
let's see we did a great job everyone
welcome back
i hope both teams were able to get
everything done in two hours
now's the fun part let's listen to each
other's songs and see what each team
came up with
let's begin with team evergreen
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[Music]
oh man i'm so nervous right now
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
oh
great work on the outro that was fire i
know it was weird like not
really getting the chance to even show
you like what where the production had
gotten to so
and you were willing to do it but i was
empowered
and i know that but you don't know what
is going on inside of me and that's okay
i'm stuck
it's not like it used to be
[Music]
you can keep your thoughts and hopes for
the haters
[Music]
her voice oh my god
[Music]
this is the best decision that i could
have made for us
that was clean i love those chord
progressions you got
pipes on you seriously yeah she carried
it
thank you these songs are all amazing
and props to all of you for pumping this
out in two hours which is crazy
we have posted these songs online and
people already voting as we speak
and let's find out which one of the two
songs will be the winner
oh god this might sound
overconfident and i don't like sounding
like that
but i do think we're gonna win
it just had a character to it you know
the way that the sounds were picked
and the way that it bounces and the way
that the vocals were mixed kayla's newer
to recording
her own vocals and i thought she killed
it now for the results
both songs were very unique with their
own flavor but there can only be
one winner the results are in and the
song that received the most votes
the winning song for today's song left
is
break up to breakthrough from team
evergreen
grass brian and dear evergreen
i've been talking so much i don't think
we're gonna win dear evergreen and brian
they had an amazing song so it was kind
of undeniable for the time that we had
i feel like we crushed it it was kind of
interesting seeing their
rivalry what's crazy is that because we
could hear each other i think that amped
up the competitiveness i was really
happy with
uh makayla's production and it was just
fun
i mean i meant what i said like you guys
the song was mad catchy i love you
you're all right
thank you so much for watching and if
you like this episode of song lab make
sure you hit that like button
and share this video with your friends
if you want to listen to these songs you
can go to spotify and other streaming
services so make sure you click the link
below
and listen to the full tracks thank you
so much and see you guys next time